hey guys to gogo here and I just want to
welcome you to the very first episode of
cold fusion for the year if you're new
year you might as well subscribe because
I'm pretty sure they're not going to
regret it and you enjoy yourself and you
might as well check out some other older
videos as well so without further ado
here's the first video enjoy guys you
are watching cold fusion TV mobile
gaming has certainly improved over the
years but has always been a world away
from consoles and PCs but that ends this
year what if I told you that it's
technically possible to play PC
PlayStation 4 and Xbox one games on a
mobile chip in a mobile device
it sounds like I'm completely mad well
just watch it all starts with Nvidia a
real dark horse in this case for years
nvidia has always been trailing behind
in the mobile tech space Tegra 2 was
woefully underpowered and Tegra 3 was
outdated unreleased because it used a
one-year old die process investors got
nervous and it was clear that Nvidia
needed to go back to the drawing board
to avoid being left behind completely
the answer the Tegra k1 with 192 GPU
cores it's set to change the way we
think about mobile gaming so what you
may think what does this mean for me
throughout the course of this short
video you'll learn a lot about what this
chip is and the significant implications
it carries firstly here's the state of
the art the best mobile chip money can
buy at the moment can render this in
real time this is where we are right now
in veer has gone far beyond today
providing next-gen graphics here's how
it looks
let's do it again the carrot
state-of-the-art and invidious next-gen
Tegra k1 chip okay so there's a few
things going on namely OpenGL 4.4 and
Unreal Engine 4 this is by far the
biggest thing to happen in mobile gaming
in its entire history this is just a
brief taste and you'll see more games
and demos later in the episode Unreal
Engine 4 controls more than just
graphics you can think of it as an
operating system for games the character
AI a physics and the whole package of
realism is all intertwined in the game
engine big deal right we'll consider
this
Unreal Engine 4 is a current gen engine
so from the Xbox one to the ps4 to your
PC all of these machines is this very
same engine in some of their games let's
hear a bit from Nvidia CEO Jensen Huang
one singular architecture all compatible
is now able to span computing from a few
watts all the way to megawatts
we've brought mobile computing to the
same level as desktop computing we've
brought mobile computing to the same
level as supercomputers that last
statement really sounds ridiculous but
technically he's correct this very same
chip can be used in anything from a
phone to a supercomputer a supercomputer
would just have more of them welcome to
fully scalable technology my friends
if you're still unsure of what this
actually means for gaming here's another
quote this one certainly knocked me out
of my chair we can take absolutely
anything that runs on PC or high-end
console and run it on Tegra I didn't
think would be at this level on mobile
for another three to four years I didn't
say it was the founder of epic games
himself that said it to quickly make
sense of that statement there was a
brilliant graphic that was used
invidious presentation basically it took
eight years for a mobile device to
achieve the graphics of a 2002 PC this
was Unreal Engine 3 and the first mobile
device to use Unreal Engine 3 was the
iPad with Infinity Blade now it's come
to the point where it's only taken two
years to achieve 2012 graphics in a
mobile device now I hope you see the
full picture so everything you're going
to see from now on is all generated from
the NVIDIA Tegra k1 chipset I let this
tech demo and gameplay footage run in
the background while I tell you a bit
about the chip the Tegra 1 will come in
two flavors providing there's no delays
this is the game plan within the first
half of 2014 there will be one version
with forearm cortex a15 cores and one
companion core and then there will be a
second version which is an absolute
screamer get this it's a dual core
64-bit chip codenamed
Denver Denver is capable of decoding
seven instructions per clock cycle
normal CPUs decode one two or three if
you're lucky
but seven is just ridiculous the two
cores are going to be custom cores made
by Nvidia based off the arm v8
architecture I'm really trying to cut
out the jargon in this video so I'll
leave it at that but it's basically
going to be a giant leap above anything
we've come across in the mobile industry
other benefits an absolute huge gain in
advanced physics simulation particle
effects lighting systems and a lot more
it's actually set to blow last gen game
consoles out of the water it obviously
goes without saying that pcs and
high-end consoles are still much more
powerful the bottom line is that for the
first time all platforms can share a
common game engine it's very reasonable
to think that mobile technology will
never get up to the graphics standards
of PCs and modern game consoles but this
attitude is quite reminiscent of those
that set that the motorcar will never
overtake the horse-and-carriage saying
never means that there's a zero percent
chance of that event happening and
that's probably not the smartest thing
to say in this situation so I know the
question that a lot of you have look
this all sounds great but how will this
actually perform within real gameplay
with a bunch of explosions and things
happening I'm going to be honest and
right now I'll say that it's probably
going to lag and as you can see in the
footage now there is a bit of framerate
stutter but it's like anything the first
handful of times a new technology is
tried and developed it's far from
perfect is the very nature of progress
but slowly and surely we start to get
things right we improve and eventually
the end result is a far cry from what we
started with right now we're at the very
infancy of mobile computing what we have
today will be looked at in the future as
the first pioneering steps perhaps to
convergence or perhaps or something else
and just think in 2015 if this mobile
graphics power doubles which is the
prediction a lot of people might have to
accept the fact that next generation
Mobile has arrived so hopefully if the
developers and NVIDIA hold true and
don't drop the ball on this one we're in
for some very exciting entertainment
next year this has been cold fusion and
thank you for watching the whole way
through as you may have noticed actually
don't really have that many subscribers
so I'm really trying to work on growing
my channel at the moment so as usual
don't forget to give a thumbs up if you
liked it and if you know someone that's
going to be interested in this kind of
thing maybe flip this video across to
him cheers guys and I'll catch you again
for the next one
cold fusion if we thinking